it was just three days ago that New York
Times reporters take Kelly and Robyn
Pogrebin were the toast of the left boy
things move fast their new book appeared
to finish the job that the national
media started a year ago and take out
Brett Kavanaugh for good the author's
accused Kavanaugh of committing a kind
of sexual assault as a college student
more than 30 years ago at Yale details
were sparse but it was enough to launch
a tsunami of rage from the left shatters
on the other cable channels immediately
denounced Kavanagh as a gang rapist
virtually all the leading Democrats
running for president demanded the cab
not be impeached and removed from office
and then almost immediately the story
fell apart Sunday night the newspaper
was forced to make a devastating
correction to the peace in fact the
woman that Cavanaugh supposedly attacked
didn't remember anything about the event
and just like so many previous stories
about Brett Kavanaugh the whole thing
turned out to be a crock so last night
Kelly and Pogrebin sought refuge on
MSNBC in fact on a show highly familiar
with botched stories that explanation
don't blame us blame our editors what
happened with that omission that the
times later felt belonged in the piece
well first of all Lawrence there was
zero intent to mislead anybody about the
details of the incident in your draft of
the article did it include those words
that have since been added to the
article it did so somewhere in the
editing process those words were I mean
I think what happened actually was that
you know we had her name and you know
The Times doesn't usually include the
name of ricktum and so I think in this
case the editors felt like maybe it was
probably better to remove it and in
removing her name they removed the other
reference to the fact that she didn't
remember and so in their removal of the
name they ended up removing what follows
yes and I mean so I think it was just
sort of an editing you know done in the
haste and in the editing process as you
know well actually that story could be
true the New York Times is not what it
used to be it's perfectly believable
that some half-asleep politically
inflamed editor at the paper would blow
one of the most important stories of the
year it's not a very impressive news
outlet anymore but a missing line is not
the only problem with this
dori watch the treatment the two authors
received of all places on the view I
understand that the woman didn't want
her name out publicly if not why is her
name in the book her name is in the book
because we think it's relevant
information we think it's accurate and
we know that her name was provided to
members of the Senate and the FBI by a
witness named max tire who is a good
governance activist in Washington who's
a respected figure and he had provided
this name the name is in documents lives
in a letter he did at one point
I understand do work for Williams and
Connolly on the piece because that is if
we're talking about credibility right I
understand it's it's it's relevant
background in this case it was a very
short mention and we only talked in
brief terms about what he's doing right
now so we didn't see all of that context
to be necessary but I understand why
you're bringing it up and I think it's
fair uh-huh just a short venture of
course it's the critical claim in the
story / book we left out some context
well it turns out some people think it's
relevant when a character destroying
smear comes from political activists
rather than from say ordinary citizens
you ought to be able to know that when
you're reading the piece the time
disagrees though they don't think you
have a right to that context of course
these are also the people who took the
Trump dossier seriously and buried the
context in that and you know in some
ways it's a shame that Kelly and
Pogrebin bungled their stories so badly
because the book actually has some
interesting revelations in it assuming
they're true for example they were the
first reporters to get an on-the-record
statement from Leland Kaiser that's the
friend of Christine vazhi Ford who
supposedly could corroborate her story
of being assaulted but in the end did
not corroborate it why didn't she well
Kaiser told the authors that she had
quote no confidence in Blasi Ford's
story that's not something the left
wants you to hear so of course the
authors downplayed that and buried it at
the very end of the book really seems
like the lead but no they downplayed it
they also downplayed another telling
fact pattern which is just how far the
left was willing to go to destroy
Cavanaugh last year
Molly Hemingway and Cary Severino also
wrote a book on the subject it's called
justice on trial and they reported that
Leland Kaiser face sustained
pressure from the left to change her
story to lie and support Blasi Ford's
account Kelly and Pogrebin found out
what exactly that pressure was they got
text messages in which Blasi Ford's
allies discuss defaming Leland Kaiser
who's a suburban mom outside DC as a
drug addict
Kaiser confirmed that this happened as
she told the two reporters quote I was
told behind the scenes that certain
things could be spread about me if I
didn't comply now that's an interesting
story from irrelevant some unsupported
gossip from a decades-old dorm party it
just happened last year the problem with
it though is that the story the truth of
it makes the activists left look like
ruthless fascists why cuz they kind of
are so the New York Times suppressed
that they didn't want you to know and
you should know that